sommet de mal la tempête n'a pas empêché
un accord presque parfait entre les deux
grands messieurs boucher gorbatchev ont
officiellement affiché leur amitié et
ont pris date pour réduire les armements
conventionnels en europe l'arsenal
nucléaire et calmer le jeu dans tous les
conflits régionaux d'amérique centrale
au proche orient
à l'est les bouleversements s'accélère
en rda l'appareil du pc démissionne le
numéro un monsieur cren assure les
affaires courantes et plusieurs anciens
dirigeants sont arrêtés tout recherché
par la police
l'élection législative partielle à dreux
et à marseille sur fond de problèmes
d'immigration le nombre des
abstentionnistes a baissé par rapport au
premier tour ee à dreux les premières
estimations donnent madame stirbois
front national élu l'arménie un an plus
tard page spéciale à la fin de cette
édition les orphelins du tremblement de
terre réapprennent à vivre et le blocus
économique imposé par la république
musulmane l'azerbaïdjan aux arméniens
retard dangereusement la reconstruction
du pays voilà monsieur bonsoir oublier
la tempête
oubliez les éléments déchaînés qui ont
soufflé sur l'île de malte pendant toute
la durée du sommet bush gorbatchev
cette météo d'enfer aura même servi à
réhausser la réussite de cette rencontre
entre les deux grands en effet cet après
midi le président américain et le numéro
un soviétique ont tenu une conférence de
presse commune ce qui n'était pas prévu
chargé de symboles ils étaient côte à
côte le sourire aux lèvres comme de
vieux amis à plusieurs reprises même ils
se sont serré la main
il faut dire que les options prises sont
d'importance plusieurs dates ont été
retenues pour réunir partenaires de
l'otan et du pacte de varsovie afin de
réduire les forces militaires en europe
pour détruire une partie également de
l'arsenal nucléaire américain et
soviétique et pour tenter de régler
plusieurs conflits régionaux de
l'amérique centrale au proche-orient à
malte des deux côtés on était donc
décidé à avancer sur place nos envoyés
spéciaux georges bortoli claude sicard
une conférence de presse commune du
président américain du numéro un
soviétique
on n'avait jamais vu cela raïssa
gorbatchev n'aurait pas voulu manquer
cela pour un empire non plus que les
journalistes qui se pressait dans le
salon du maxime gorki
le bateau qui a été la résidence de
monsieur gorbatchev pendant ce sommet de
malte conférence de presse tout à fait
détendus par exemple monsieur gorbatchev
constate une note que vient de lui faire
passer monsieur bush est en anglais et
il ajoute je ne sais pas lire l'anglais
alors je vais lui répondre en russe on
rit de bon coeur et on face aux choses
sérieuses notamment au désarmement le
désarmement explique monsieur gorbatchev
nous en avons beaucoup parlé et nous
avons donné des instructions à nos
ministres des affaires étrangères pour
que le traité sur les armes chimiques
soient prêts à notre prochaine rencontre
en juin
autre grand moment monsieur bush
souhaite que le pima permettent aux
hommes d'affaires américains d'aidé
monsieur gorbatchev dans sa tâche de
piri stralka et deux classes noces ce
qui devrait mettre du baume sur le coeur
des soviétiques qui ont désespérément
besoin d'investissements étrangers et un
peu plus tard dans une interview aux
télévisions américaines mais chez bush
ne cachait pas sa satisfaction après
cette rencontre de mal
nous n'avons pas résolu tous les
problèmes existant entre les états unis
et l'union soviétique ni les problèmes
qui ont existé ces dernières années
entre l'automne entre l'europe de
l'ouest et les pays de l'est mais nous
comprenons mieux d'où ces problèmes
viennent
et ceci est très important monsieur
quand belles choses qu'on prend nos
priorités il comprend l'inquiétude que
je ressens au sujet de la mairie
centrale les rencontres reggane
gorbatchev avec leur dramatisation c'est
bien
ni maintenant on dédramatise monsieur
gorbatchev a même poussé le bouchon
jusqu'à jurer qu'il était pour des
élections libres au nicaragua ce qui
équivaut un début de lâchage des grands
alliés de moscou en amérique centrale
c'est-à-dire les sandiniste
alors qu'est ce qu'il a obtenu en
contrepartie de cette obligeance
peut-être la petite phrase que vous
venez d'entendre dans laquelle monsieur
bush invite les hommes d'affaires
américains à investir en urss
bien sûr les business men américains
feront ce qu'ils voudront mais tout de
même me g bush a donné clairement un
témoignage qu'il souhaitait réinsérer
l'économie soviétique dans l'ensemble de
l'économie mondiale
oui aussitôt après leur conférence de
presse commune les deux chefs d'état ont
regagné l'un moscou monsieur gorbatchev
pour tenir une réunion avec ses
partenaires du pacte de varsovie
de l'autre côté monsieur george bush a
pris la direction de bruxelles ou demain
aura lieu une réunion de l'otan
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord monsieur george bush en pleine
forme boule voyez le sommet de malte n'a
pas mise entre parenthèses l'avalanche
de bouleversement en europe de l'est en
rda aujourd'hui dimanche le bureau
politique du pc a démissionné en bloc
monsieur egon krenz le numéro un n'est
pas sûr de conserver son poste et la
chasse aux anciens dirigeants corrompus
s'accélère le dernier chef de l'état le
plus puissant monsieur à necker a été
exclu du pcc et trois autres dirigeants
de l'ancien régime ont été arrêtés pour
corruption un quatrième ancien ministre
du commerce extérieur lui est recherché
par la police et la population elle
continue d'appuyer ces bouleversements
qu elles jugent encore insuffisants
berlin philippe rochot erichot necker
expulsé du parti avec vili stoff gunther
mittag l'économiste tous les grands noms
de l'ancien régime
livrée aux sifflets de la foule par
gunter schabowski qui était responsable
du parti pour la région de berlin il ne
restait plus qu'une dizaine de membres
sur 25 au comité central
ils ont tous démissionné en bloc quinze
jours avant le congrès du parti
egon krenz à un plan c'est la fuite egon
prends ton chapeau et vatan modrow
premier ministre tu peux rester
les autres doivent partie
la personnalité même du secrétaire
général du parti était mise en cause
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines erichot
necker quant à lui qui le 7 octobre
dernier tron est encore aux côtés de
gorbatchev et des dirigeants aujourd'hui
condamné comme gunther mittag est accusé
de détournement de fonds de corruption
et d'avoir pillé les biens du peuple
avec le patron des syndicats hariti ch
qui vient d'être arrêté dans la rue des
manifestants
comme cet homme existe un procès et une
condamnation de ses dirigeants chaque
jour dit il la presse nous apporte des
révélations sur les scandales qui
touchent nos hommes politiques
malheureusement on apprend toujours de
cette manière est jamais directement
mais c'est ainsi ce vaste coup de balai
ou parti communiste est aussi le
résultat de la pression populaire
ils étaient 2 millions ce matin à
l'appel de l'église et des mouvements
d'opposition
ils ont bloqué les tramways pour
réaliser du nord au sud de la rda et
d'est en ouest cette immense chaîne
humaine
ils demandaient par là une alternative
aux deux systèmes capitalistes où vit la
rfa et communiste où a vécu jusque là
l'allemagne de l'est
1300 km de chaînes ont été ainsi
réalisés dans le froid et dans le
brouillard
beaucoup auraient voulu que cette chaîne
puisse s'étendre jusqu'à l'allemagne
fédérale mais refus de l'église
protestante
nous ne manifestons pas pour la
réunification allemande ont ils dit mais
simplement pour le renouveau
démocratique du pays l'est encore à
prague le nouveau gouvernement
tchécoslovaque formé aujourd'hui sous la
direction du même premier ministre
monsieur adamek compte pour la première
fois cinq ministres non communiste il
est vrai à des postes de moindre
importance ce qui provoque d'ailleurs la
colère de l'opposition et l'appel à de
nouvelles manifestations de rue dès
demain mais pour tenter de calmer le jeu
le gouvernement insiste pour entamer
rapidement des négociations avec l'urss
sur le retrait des troupes de l'armée
rouge stationnaient toujours en
tchécoslovaquie
et puis le président de la république
monsieur ou sac au pouvoir depuis 1968
envisage d' utile de démissionner
corinne pertuis la tchécoslovaquie se
donne un nouveau gouvernement
mais à y regarder de plus près les
hommes ne sont pas neufs sur vingt
ministres cet été dans l'ancien
gouvernement et 5 ne sont pas membres du
parti communiste 5 seulement
même si c'est une grande première depuis
1948 les tchécoslovaques s'attendait à
mieux que sur vingt ministres 15 soit
communiste
c'est inacceptable inacceptable dit cet
homme pour y fier quand même de
démontrer sa volonté de réforme
l'équipe de monsieur adamek a
immédiatement annoncé que la
tchécoslovaquie allait se doter d'une
économie de marché et que des
négociations seraient entamées sur le
retrait des troupes soviétiques
mais cela n'a pas suffi à l'opposition
le forum civique a aussitôt appelé à une
manifestation demain à prague
mais dès ce soir les prévoir sur la
place venceslas demande la démission de
ce gouvernement et plus de non
communiste au pouvoir
ils savent que les réformateurs ne
peuvent se trouver à l'intérieur du
parti
ils ont été massivement exclu dans les
années 70 le président de la république
lui-même gustav husak envisage
maintenant démissionner l'opposition lui
donne une semaine pour le faire à
l'étranger encore aux philippines fin de
la tentative de coup d'état militaire
contre la présidente cory aquino
900 kg schiste ont été arrêtés mais le
dernier bilan des combats qui ont eu
lieu principalement en ville fait état
d' un millier de tués moore et puis
aussi pas mal de blessés la plupart des
civils bien entendu c'est la sixième
tentative de coup d'état avorté contre
la présidente madame cory aquino
en france on attend ce soir le résultat
de deux élections législatives
partielles qui se sont déroulés à
marseille et à dreux sur fond de
problèmes d'immigration est d'abord donc
à dreux dans la grande banlieue
parisienne où une candidate du front
national madame stirbois la veuve de
l'ancien numéro deux du parti de jean
marie le pen est bien placé pour
l'emporter au second tour à dreux on
retrouve tout de suite
roland sicard voulons les résultats dans
une ambiance très chaude
marie france stirbois l'emportent avec
plus de 60% des voix 61% des voix
semble-t-il
alors je vous propose qui suit si vous
le voulez bien d'écouter la réaction de
marie france stirbois ve que nous avons
recueillis tout à l'heure une réaction
vous allez le voir recueilli là encore
dans une ambiance très chaude
tél vous donnez à votre histoire
signification c'est que le peuple
français on à tête france et de cette
bande des cas de magouilleurs et moi je
me suis rendu compte pendant toute cette
campagne je ne suis pas une table je
n'ai pas fait campagne de nos tares j'ai
été vers les gens j'ai défendu les
français je crois que c'est ça la
lamizana dit tu prends des gens en ont
assez de ces demandes les plâtres qui
est prête à tout faire pour défendre ses
privilèges d environ 116 les autres
alors voilà on voulait ajouter quelque
chose oui oui je crois que ces résultats
appellent quand même au moins de
commentaires
premier commentaire c'est le succès
personnels de madame stirbois madame
c'est moi qui ai fait une campagne très
active sur le terrain contrairement à
son adversaire michel dussuyer cette
campagne sur le terrain à payer et puis
second commentaire c'est l'échec du
front anti le pen vous savez que les
partis de gauche le parti socialiste et
le parti communiste au moins à paris
avait appelé à voter rpr et bien cet
appel semble-t-il a eu tout un effet
repoussoir une partie en tout cas des
électeurs du rpr et de l'udf ont préféré
voter front national que mélanger leurs
voix à celles de la gauche
voilà daniel c'est ce qu'on peut dire
pour l'instant merci roland donc les
résultats en direct dans ce journal à
l'instant même donc et puis à marseille
donc la deuxième élection l'iss l'atv il
s'agit là de remplacer le député udf
jean claude gaudin devenu sénateur la la
candidate du front national madame
russell n'est pas aussi favori que
madame stirbois dreux mais son score est
à suivre de près et marseille patrice
venait jean-françois giorgetti un
frémissement dans la mobilisation à 17
heures cet après-midi 30,6 % de votants
soit 5 points de mieux que dimanche
dernier
et pourtant dans cette 2e
circonscription de marseille la gauche
n'offrait plus de candidats aux
électeurs aucun n'avait passé au premier
tour la barre des douze ennemis % des
inscrits duel à droite donc jean
françois mattei udf rpr favori de jean
claude gaudin face à marie claude
roussel front national une campagne
à l'opposé entre les deux candidats l'un
parle de valeurs humaines et de vérité
l'autre dit non tchador non à la mosquée
un dilemme pour les communistes et les
socialistes 7 et 13 % au premier tour
leur parti a appelé cette semaine à
voter mattei
le front national il trouve là une
preuve qu'il est le seul à droite le
candidat écologiste 6% à l'essai lui
libre choix à ses électeurs
alors où sont allés aujourd'hui ces
voies orpheline de candidats la réponse
est dans les urnes et jean françois
mattei à ce soir la faveur du pronostic
oui là en l'occurrence à marseille les
bureaux de vote ont fermé à 20 heures et
nous n'avons pas les résultats ni une
estimation pour l'instant donc les
résultats sans doute dans notre dernier
journal
fait divers un accident vraiment stupide
mais meurtrier ce matin dans un stand de
tir de la banlieue bruxelloise une balle
a ricoché dans un mur mettant le feu au
local bilan douze morts claude crespo en
libye l'explosion s'est produite dans le
sous sol de ce bâtiment en construction
en effet déjà s'y était installé un club
de tir ce dimanche matin sans doute pour
pimenter le jeu
les membres du stand ont pris comme
cible un bloc moteur est entre copains
bon on a essayé comment fait que ça près
comme comme impact sera à 4 aux voitures
sera un truc comme ça en étant l
regarder ce que ce bloc moteur avec une
réaction à voir avec la puce c'est entre
intérêts sur un bloc moteur
double messieurs au compteur se trouve à
15 mètres de nous il semblerait qu'une
balle et rebondit sur une paroi en
février ça provoque une inflammation et
puis une explosion une explosion dont le
souffle a été si puissant que certaines
victimes ont été blastés c'est à dire
qu'elles ont fui leurs organes écrasés
ce soir à bruxelles les enquêteurs
envisagerait une autre hypothèse de cet
accident que la maladresse
l'accumulation de poudre dans un local
un suffisamment aéré et un coup de feu
aurait provoqué l'explosion et
l'incendié qui a suivi
une enquête est évidemment pour pour
déterminer les causes de l'accident
je vous le rappelle a provoqué la mort
de 12 personnes
pas dit que huit autres auraient été
blessées et dans trois ce soir encore
serait dans un état sérieux notre page
spéciale maintenant comme annoncé dans
les titres l'arménie un an plus tard
douze mois après le tremblement de terre
du 7 décembre 1988 dont le bilan
officiel a été évaluée je vous le
rappelle à 25 mille morts hier soir dans
notre édition de 20 heures nous avons
constaté ensemble est les problèmes
posés par la reconstruction
intéressons-nous maintenant aux
conséquences sur ceux qui ont survécu et
particulièrement les enfants orphelins
grâce à l'aide internationale notamment
ils sont regroupés prise en charge et il
s'agit maintenant non pas de leur faire
oublier mais de leur réapprendre à vivre
le plus normalement possible reporter
rémy roche france brisset
salle de soins intensifs dans une unité
pédiatrique de lénine à cannes l'hôpital
a été réaménagé avec l'aide de médecins
sans frontières dans une école en face
des ruines de l'ancien bâtiment une
seule prise de courant pour alimenter
l'ensemble des installations fournis par
la cee
pas d'eau courante les médecins se lave
les mains dans une bassine situation
sanitaire déplorable dans la ville
effondré compétence médicale
insuffisante salaires dérisoires donc
démotivant manque de médicaments une
maladie banale chez nous prend ici trop
vite des proportions dramatiques à
l'hôpital numéro 2 de lénine à cannes
un enfant meurt presque chaque jour
banlieue de spitak la ville martyre
rayés de la carte
1400 personnes ont été relogées dans ce
village provisoire livrée clé en main
par les italiens les enfants qui
habitent ces préfabriqués trois étoiles
sont tous des orphelins de père de mère
ou des deux parents
c'est cela qui suivent une leçon
arménien était bien sûr à l'école le 7
décembre 1988
11h41 l'école s'est écroulé 200 de leurs
camarades et 14 professeurs ont été tués
la rentrée dans les nouveaux locaux
s'est faite en septembre sans
enthousiasme
certains ont d'ailleurs refusé de
reprendre le chemin de l'école devenu le
symbole de l'horreur et de la mort et ça
n'est pas sans difficultés parfois que
les maîtres eux mêmes durement éprouvée
dans leur famille doivent faire face à
ces regards absents
si l'on chante c'est à la gloire des
héros mythiques de l'arménie comme pour
demander à l'aide
matériellement les élèves ont tout ce
qu'il faut pour apprendre les italiens
ont bien fait les choses
ils n'ont rien oublié et nous marquons
pas de manuels mais les enfants ont
perdu la foi
certes il faut ce qu'on leur demande
mais le coeur n'y est plus ils ne sont
pas prêts d'oublier psychiatres et
psychologues occidentaux dont plusieurs
organisations ont mis en place des
structures d'accueil est-il que dans les
zones sinistrées
90% des enfants risquent de subir plus
ou moins durablement
l'ondé de choc troubles du sommeil
bégaiement régression et retard scolaire
avec des conséquences à terme difficile
à évaluer le risque est de faire
apparaître des adultes qui auront des
difficultés de se prendre en charge
je fais des symptômes qui apparaîtront
souvent et qui les gênent rond dans leur
vie
il n'est pas possible d'oublier et ça
n'est pas souhaitable ajoute même les
spécialistes de médecins du monde qui
invite au contraire les enfants à parler
de leurs tremblement de terre à
l'exprimer par le dessin le mime ou tout
autre moyen
un objectif classique de la
psychothérapie qui consiste à prendre
conscience de ses angoisses et de ses
traumatismes pour mieux les accepter
c'est vrai qu'ils sont plus plus
adaptées plus à l'aise dans les groupes
souvent au moins déprimés ou bien moins
angoissé qu'au départ au niveau du
terrain chez eux à l'école on n'a pas
encore pas suffisamment de recul pour
pouvoir répondre à cette question
le programme des psycho logique de
médecins du monde vient de démarrer
il doit durer trois ans d'ici là au
mieux quelques milliers d'enfants auront
été aidés mais ils sont plus de 50
milles ces garçons et ces filles brisé
de la génération tremblement de terre
et aux problèmes posés par les lenteurs
administratives maintenant inhérentes au
régime soviétique qu'il faut ajouter
pour l'arménie pour ce qui concerne sa
reconstruction un autre handicap le
conflit territorial et religieux qui
oppose les chrétiens arméniens aux
musulmans d'asie rebadgée et
malheureusement pour l'arménie
le pays est enclavé de telle sorte que
toute l'aide qu'elle reçoit des autres
républiques de l'urss
transis par l'azerbaïdjan qui
officiellement ou officieusement ce
livre un blocus aux conséquences
désastreuses pour la reconstruction des
zones sinistrées reporter thiery
calmette dominique merde blocs ada
blocus au sud de l'arménie et gars
gardes-frontière terre de fertilité à
l'ombre du mont ararat tu ou non et
déposa son art au trafic réduit alors
que 95% des marchandises importées dans
ce pays doivent circuler par chemin de
fer tout trains à destination des
réveils traverse obligatoirement
l'azerbaïdjan aujourd'hui la ligne se
détournent suit les frontières par le
nhs a rich evans également sous
administration azérie juillet-août 89
un wagon sur trois attaquer ou piller
les sens mais les halos les pommes de
terre arrosée de détergents ou les
wagons simplement immobilisé durant des
jours
et surtout les doumic maisons
préfabriquées indispensable à la survie
valises et ça continue ce train arrive
de bakou capitale azérie nous étions là
c'était la semaine dernière
un abri de moins pour une famille
arménienne
macadam en à votre rang que le blocus
est organisée par le gouvernement azéri
et avec l'aide du peuple azéri c'est
fait exprès pour qu après le séisme
l'aide extérieure n'arrive pas c'est une
lutte qui dure depuis des siècles mais
les ordres viennent d'en haut pour nous
faire agenouiller pour empêcher le monde
entier de nous aider au mois d'août sur
un convoi de 12/100 nomi 450 rendu
inutilisable arménie et azerbaïdjan deux
républiques soviétiques
que fait l'armée rouge pourquoi ne pas
protéger les convois
garde erevan drapeaux arméniens et
horaires de moscou une heure locale de
mois le responsable des chemins de fer
arménien tente de justifier en langue
russe très officiellement si le
gouvernement central de moscou avait
pris des mesures dès le début du blocus
alors aujourd'hui nous n'aurions pas des
conséquences désastreuses se battent le
23 août je crois pourtant monsieur
gorbatchev a dressé une résolution au
gouvernement d'azerbaïdjan leur
enjoignant de cesser le blocus mais en
dépit de cela le blocus a continué à et
le 7 octobre les azéri ont changé leur
méthode de blocus ils les soldats c'est
les wagons de nourriture et de matériel
mais il bloque les citernes de carburant
c'est un blocus tout aussi efficace un
blocus sélectif aggravée par l'hiver des
revan les camions franchissent le défilé
de d'aline pour atteindre l'épicentre du
séisme
difficilement praticables conséquence
gêner le travail de l'international
bloquer les secours d'urgence
mr semaine on a travaillé dans la rue
parce qu'on n'arrive pas de local pour
travailler
en attendant de pouvoir loger dans les
migros loge à l'hôtel où on est à 5 par
chambre sur des matelas par terre avec
un robinet d'eau froide dix personnes
sans toit n'est qu'un petit peu la
situation
autres conséquences aggravées le marché
noir pour la nourriture une situation
déjà endémique
quand tu veux
quand même pas lieu
15 avril
sur le même trottoir dimanche le marché
libre d revan une impression d'opulence
mais remarqué aucun prix d'affiché pas
d'étiquette légumes ou viande de 3,5
fois plus cher que le prix officiel
et ici on n'aime pas les questions dans
les magasins d'état la pénurie criante
avant le magasin a été vite parce qu'il
n'y avait rien mais aujourd'hui les
produits sont là mais il n'y a pas
d'essence pour les transporter jusqu ici
le problème ce n'est pas le magasin vite
c'est parce que dans la zone du séisme
ce qui nous aide n'avait plus rien à
manger et beaucoup sont repartis le mont
ararat tu protèges mal les arméniens
autres représailles la route de
stepanakert capitale du haut karabagh
bloquaient aussi par les azéris le
symbole du nationalisme arménien réduit
à la famine
pour combien de temps encore oui dernier
reportage de cette série sur l'arménie
un an plus tard dans notre dernier
journal consacré à la reconstruction de
la principale ville touchée par le
séisme
lénine à cannes retour en france pour
terminer cette édition avec un concert
vraiment pas comme les autres le groupe
antillais kassav de n'être vendredi soir
un concert à la prison de fleury mérogis
ce sont les animateurs du printemps de
bourges qui ont eu l'idée d'organiser
ses tournées dans les établissements
pénitentiaires
le spectacle de vendredi soir vu par un
spectateur détenus reporter bruno gex
jean-françois cheveux
à 7 heures du matin la porte s'ouvre
petit déjeuner de 8h à 10h et retourna à
midi c'est la bouffe à deux heures c'est
la plus mal encore deux heures à 4
heures on revient et la bouffe est la
cisr un jour pas comme les autres il est
deux heures du matin les musiciens du
groupe kassav franchissent les portes du
pénitencier pour charlie les 470 jeunes
détenus de fleury mérogis
c'est un moment exceptionnel ces
artistes là le savent bien
midi c'est l'heure du repas patrick et
jean philippe les deux chanteur de
kassav sont autorisés à rencontrer le
détenu 78 1307 n
et puis on venait aussi au nom du casse
à gaza on voulait donner un peu de punch
aussi comme le zoom comme la musique
puis voilà ouais année problème
ouais
14h30 fin de la promenade fouilles et de
haut en bas un premier groupe de 200 35
détenus et conduit vers le gymnase c'est
là que le concert doit avoir lieu
désigné pour présenter les musiciens
charlie 19 ans et l'animateur radio de
fleury en prison depuis 10 mois encore
90 jours a tiré aujourd'hui il a les
honneurs du public
et ça tombe bien
passe complètement c'est complètement
décontracté quoi sont à l'aise et bon
finalement ça se passait
c'est mieux passé que ce qu'on pensait
grâce à eux jamais vu une ambiance comme
ça c'est vrai ce terrain moi quand je
vais entrer chez m le style propre
il est un peu de musique et je vais
manger c'est pas avec mon monde et nous
par un bon camarade quoi
voilà 18h30
le concert est finie la nuit déjà tous
ont regagné leurs cellules
c'était un jour pas comme les autres à
la prison de fleury mérogis
voilà il me reste à vous donner les
résultats des courses de ce dimanche à
auteuil de tiercé pour gagner il fallait
jouer las le 9 et le 11
ça rapporte 732 francs et 50 centimes
pour ce qui concerne le quarté + c'est
bien ajouter à l'assaut neuf et onze le
7 et vous gagnez 3847 francs et 20
centimes voilà ce journal est terminée
tout de suite après les prévisions météo
de lundi et du début de la semaine avec
josé dans la pierre en détails aux
alentours de 23h15 les dernières
informations avec philippe gassot et
notamment les résultats de l'élection
partielle de marseille vous avez tout à
l'heure celle de dreux avec les premiers
commentaires donc après l'élection de
madame stirbois du front national et
puis bien sûr nous reviendrons en détail
sur le sommet s'est tout même ben là
aussi très important le sommet de malte
entre monsieur bush et gorbatchev
n'oubliez pas non plus en exclusivité
sur antenne 2 ce soir cette nuit à 0
heures 45 la finale du tournoi de tennis
des master's à new york
et puis demain soir ici même vous
retrouverez christine ockrent pour une
semaine quand à moi et toute l'équipe du
week-end nous vous retrouverons avec
beaucoup de plaisir samedi prochain dès
13h au revoir bonne semaine